bonjour guy mettan
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france nathalie
l'oiseau qui parle donc d'une offre
d'une suisse molle comme ans a été
accueillie chez vous écoutez ici ça plus
tôt il était pris dans l'indifférence
apartheid gros buzz mais je dois dire
que quand j'ai découvert ça sur les
réseaux sociaux ne savait pas s'il
fallait rire ou prêts ou pleurer rire à
cause de ridicule de cette phase et
pleuré à cause de sa vulgarité
effectivement ça donne une impression
détestable au fond du discours politique
actuellement français ta capacité
d'analysé des conflits internationaux
par l'élite française rappelons quand
même que
nathalie loiseau a été a été ministre
mais c'est vrai que ça fait suite à la
fameuse phrase de d'emmanuel macro sont
fait qu'ils veulent ils désiraient
emmerder les non vaccinés ça montre 10
en tout cas vu le suisse le niveau
disons excécrable débat politique
actuellement en france ce que je
voudrais aussi rappeler celle que
l'ambassadeur de suisse messieurs
balzaretti a très bien répondu il a
aussi rappelé que faisait la suisse en
ukraine
la suisse est toujours positionné comme
une puissance petit évidemment puissance
mais de négociation d'interposition de
mise à disposition de ses ressources
pour faire dialoguer les uns et les
autres mais celle derrière ce que nous
faisons je rappelle que la suisse
représente les intérêts russes en
géorgie et les intérêts géorgiens en
russie donc ce n'est pas rien représente
aussi les intérêts américains en iran
donc la suisse joue quand même un rôle
de
facilitation du dialogue qui n'est pas
l'église 1 et enfin juste pour conclure
un petit pied de nez je rappellerai n'y
a pas plus tard qu une heure ce matin en
suisse dans l'épreuve reine des jeux
olympiques la descente a battu 1
français devenu le champion olympique
devant français ceci pour rappeler à
madame l'oiseau que la suisse est un
voisin qui n'est pas si mou que ça qui
n'est pas mou du tout a priori
en mal c'est la comparaison et clarifie
ce qui fait même pas partie de l'europe
finalement
oui et puis et puis disons ce qui est
affligeant c'est cela c'est la réponse
qu'elle fait cela c'est la capacité au
fond de la france et notamment de cette
ancienne ministre députée européenne a
proposé pour l'ukraine une solution
valable ce qu'elle aurait pu dire si
elle avait été
digne de sa fonction sera puis à
l'ukraine qu'elle devait appliquer les
accords de mines ce qu'elle devait
cesser au fond de nous harceler la
minorité russe entre guillemets minorité
puisse quand même et russophone
55% de la population ukrainienne mais
surtout que le rôle de l'europe et ça a
été rappelé d'ailleurs par plusieurs de
vos intervenants tout à l'heure était au
fond d' faciliter la tâche et surtout
d'aider à la halle à l'application des
accords de miss qui ont été signés par
des grèves or ça n'est pas du tout ni
cas et personne ne prend la peine enfin
très peu de gens au niveau politique en
france on verra ce qu emmanuel macron va
faire tout à l'heure à moscou mais au
fond c'est engagé et et aspect c'est de
faire pression amicalement sans doute
sur l'ukraine pour qu'elle applique ces
accords justement à nathalie l'oiseau
voulait mettre en exergue
l'impuissance de l'europe à s'entendre
sur une position commune sur l'ukraine
emmanuel macron par part seul à moscou
est ce que vous pensez que c'était la
bonne méthode est ce qu'il n'aurait pas
fallu y associer les européens
écoutez emmanuel macron être président
en ce moment l'union européenne donc il
a la double qualité à la fois qu'un
président français et président mineurs
plein tour pour intervenir j'imagine
qu'il s'est concerté avec
l'allemagne puisqu'on sait que son seul
échec sandra moscou le 14 février donc
j'imagine que les discussions qui n'est
pas parti tout seul et son biscuit et si
vous permettez l'expression
j'espère qu'il arrivera avec des
propositions concrètes et notamment
justement par rapport aux accords de
minsk est au format normandie dont la
france et l'allemagne son ombre
évidemment que s'il arrivait avec rien
dans son analyse à ce moment-là et
donnerait l'image disons assez pitoyable
de l'union européenne on verra cela en
tout cas on suivra cela de très près
bravo pour la performance olympique que
vous avez rappelé ce matin
merci vous trouviez mettant merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct dans la matinale de rtl france